hello folks uh we're doing now playing
of overwatch it's launch day uh i'm eric
i'm here to join with mike mccarty hey
uh we like most of you are getting this
right now
uh i kind of gave blizzard the benefit
of the doubt and thought that this
wasn't going to be an issue
um but we're playing the waiting game
that is trying to join a server
uh no idea how
anyone else is faring currently um
but uh hopefully we can get in here i
told mike
that if we didn't get in in about
like
10 to 15 minutes we'll probably just
call it
because
yeah we have a review in progress up on
the site if you want to go check that
out
i wonder if i can show that somehow i
might be able to let me see
let me see if we can do some wizardy
here
where is it mike
you sure
yeah go to
go to recent
like uh this is popular i think you're
in popular right now am i let's see
just it'll get promoted there it is
all right oh that's a video though
i thought for some reason it would lead
me to the written piece
it should
uh you know what i bet the recent one
all right bet you it's pro mode huh it's
right there oh this one okay
um
what does this take me to
blank
that's us that's an intro
which one of these scenes is free
i guess this one anyways you can go to
gamespot.com
check out mike's
current review in progress
um there's only a few things you need to
see right left
in terms of like what it's not in the
actual game essentially a full review
also written but i just want to make
sure like nothing changed since the beta
i'm gonna cancel this and try to
okay once you get out yeah we could also
goo brought up a good point which is
something i jokingly said earlier we can
also play some of the hero guides that
we've been doing yeah like in the
meantime as it tries to connect
um
which you would have to alt tab too
i guess and then pull up a browser yeah
that's um
kind of unfortunate what's up marwan of
s2k
how are you doing i should pause that
stream there
a stream of server connection errors
yeah error 33. so go to youtube for
those
yeah youtube we've got a bunch over
there
the waiting game has begun that's
correct villius uh in the youtube chat
um so we have a whole playlist of them
um so yeah i want to play one and then i
can play mccree sure
i'll pull up the audio once you kind of
get actually it might no okay to filling
a more traditional
role in the hero list of overwatch
mccree is one of those number one dudes
the gunslinger from the wild west uh
chris waters here folks with mike
mchardy here to talk you through the
basics of this gunslinger and how to do
the damage with uh his big magnum the
peacekeeper mike yeah this thing's
awesome not only because it can be
really powerful but it's also pretty
accurate if you're skilled with him he's
a skilled character or you have to be
skilled to play him at least and you can
fan the hammer up close you can shoot it
from far away obviously you have six
shots uh there's a way you know to
reload it instantly with a dodge roll
he's a really dirty character overall
which is why i really like him he can
function solo on his own and the
peacekeeper is kind of the catalyst for
all of that he does some dirty stuff on
the flank for sure but let's start with
the basics the peacekeeper has two fire
modes you can fire single shots up to
six or you could fan the hammer and just
unload all the bullets that are left in
your clip in one go the single shot is
really solid for doing damage on the
main objective you know you're you're
you're picking off heroes you're
hassling supports at you know mid-range
and yeah you do need to land your shots
so if you're not super confident landing
those shots you know you're going to
want to ease into mccree but uh the fan
the hammer is where things start getting
really dirty that's him unloading real
quick when's the best time to use that
mike it's really good against anyone
really it's harder to control but it's
awesome for taking out tanks you can go
into a room and just fan the hammer if
you land all six shots you could take
out roadhog you take out reinhardt you
can take out diva's mech it's really
powerful it's also kind of
overpowered if you know how to use it
really well if you can do one and then
his uh dodge roll the combat roll
ability instantly reloads it so you can
fan the hammer all six shots kill it you
know best case scenario kill a roadhog
dodge roll automatically there's no
reload animation the gun's just ready to
go fan the hammer six more times kill
any other character and especially with
tanks they're easy to hit with all those
six shots right but you do have to be
pretty close for those shots to all land
on the character and so when you're in
close mccree is not actually a very fast
character and so you rely on one big key
ability to help arrest the mobility of
others and that's the flashbang the
flashbang is awesome it's my favorite
part because it's such a great counter
to almost anyone like the bigger
characters you don't need it as much but
if you're going against reaper or tracer
or diva in her pilot form traditionally
elusive characters it's great it stuns
them fan the hammer is going to kill
anybody in that state it's also a great
chance to get away if you need to if
you're kind of too close to reaper for
comfort it's a great escape mechanism as
well yeah the flashbang and fan the
hammer combo is where mccree goes to
town so be very comfortable with that
the combat role for the quick reload
then you can fan the hammer right again
if you need to if you missed some of
your shots or if you're taking on a tank
and you need a little extra help
important to keep in mind that mccree
also doesn't have a ton of health so one
widowmaker shot and you're going to be
in trouble so even though you can heckle
her at range that's really not a fight
you want to pick you want to stay on
those flanks mccree does best when he's
one on one and that's where you want to
do your business now let's talk about
his ultimate dead eye deadeye is tough
to master but if you know how to use it
it is deadly so how do you use it so
it's best to activate it kind of when
you're in cover so you because he walks
even slower than his normal really slow
pace you come around a corner and you'll
take about two seconds to zero in on
anybody in your sight
and then even when they go behind cover
you'll still have the target on them but
when you decide to pull the trigger is
pretty crucial because you want to make
sure all these red skulls you're seeing
which indicate you're about to kill them
no matter what character with one shot
you want to make sure they're not behind
cover so you can maximize how many
people you kill the reason you do it
from behind cover is because whenever
you activate it mccree goes
it's high noon and everyone on the map
starts looking around trying to find
mccree and also you start glowing a
little bit orange so you are easy to
spot so that's why if you're out of the
easy visual range and then you kind of
saunter around the corner that's a good
way to sort of avoid getting yourself
shot because mccree's ultimate is very
interruptible so if you're a widowmaker
a hanzo uh you know any kind of
precision shot getting close try to take
out that mccree if you're a winston if
you're may if you're reinhardt get up
your shield get up your ice wall those
are counters to mccree's ultimate
because this is potentially the most
powerful ultimate in the game but yeah
you trade a lot of damage for even more
vulnerability than he usually has all
right thanks mike that is mccree for you
folks deadly on the flanks in one on one
with those flash bang fan the hammer
engagements and also a pretty dirty dude
down the main lane uh with his ultimate
and with his mid-range peacekeeping
abilities for more overwatch tips be
sure to subscribe to gamespot and come
on back we'll have a whole roster for
you here soon enough
yeah we'll go to another one my bad guys
i know you had about half of that video
of just watching me like stare at a
screen or a phone
apologies there um mike's gonna queue up
another one i think this one's farah
we've got a bunch of these guides about
a third of the roster currently and
we're going to do more but this time
i'll switch to it
danny o'dwyer danny let's start with the
basics what does farah do sarah is
basically the sort of team fortress 2
soldier of this video game she is the
rocket launcher class is the sort of
easiest way of putting it uh she's all
about hassling the opposition she's all
about dealing damage on you know
individuals on groups as well and
killing people quick and getting the
hell out of there yeah that rocket has
splash damage so you don't have to hit
the person directly you can hit
something near them or you can hit
groups so you just want to be throwing
those rockets in there and the best
place to do that is from on hot yeah for
sure in fact positioning is basically
the most important thing with her her
abilities as you said rocket launcher
basically just shoots out rockets at a
pretty steady rate she also has a
concussive blast which does deal damage
but is mostly used for disrupting people
you know knocking uh snipers off of
their positions and sort of splitting
groups apart as well it's also really
good for using against shields because
it does quite a lot of damage against
those so if there's a reinhardt coming
at you for instance uh really good to
use that there yeah if someone's
charging in at you if someone's coming
real close you push them back and that's
one of the things about overwatch is
positioning is huge and concussive blast
also a fun way to push people off a
ledge if you can swing it yeah if
they're quite close to it it's always a
real treat to try and knock them off our
old rocket barrage real good for
taking out groups of people especially
if you're standing right above them i
mean positioning for that one's really
important making sure there's not like a
sniper around making sure there's not a
turret around as well if you can get a
group of people maybe on the point uh
unleash your alts the serious damage
yeah and it recharges fairly quickly
it's one of the faster ones so use it
often uh one of the trickiest fera alts
i got was someone just came in a doorway
like three of me and my teammates were
in a room she blew us all up but yeah
big damage and combos really well with
uh something like zarya's alts you know
look for opportunities for people in
groups just to blow them all up yeah
when it comes to para like positioning
is everything get in the air make sure
that you are using rooftops for resting
that you're not stuck sort of with gen
pop in the middle of the fight because
you're gonna get yourself attacked a lot
more there and she's also useful for
flanking so if you can find a sort of an
odd way around the map to maybe take out
a turret that's hanging out back there
or a widow maker especially snipers and
you should really be attacking him in
fact if there is a bastion on that map
and you're pharah you need that is your
responsibility you need to be blowing up
bastion you need to blow up torbjorn's
turrets yeah and don't forget about the
uh hover you can
use your jet pack to like get on ledges
it doesn't always have to be the uh jump
jet that launches used directly into the
air hovering is a great way to maneuver
on the map and be careful a temptation
is just to sort of sit up in the sky and
rain down death that's a great way to
get yourself sniped so again mobility is
key with pharah pop up pop back down pop
up pop back down exactly i mean you can
take out widowmakers and turrets with
fire really easily you can just as
easily make yourself an easy target for
those people if you launch up in the air
too early if you're going after
widowmaker don't jump and fly towards
her jump once you're at her feet because
she's gonna have a really hard time
looking up with a sniper scope to try
and take you out and that's how you
basically do that and that's a really
important sort of aspect with her i mean
the other thing is to focus fire on
tanks as much as possible the thing with
fire is you can shoot really really high
damage from quite far away so you can
stay back you don't need to be the front
of the pack you can stay back and as
long as you've got eyes on the melee
that's there just keep lobbing rockets
in there over and over and then change
position because they know where you are
you know mercy's got the angel wings but
picture yourself like the guardian angel
of your team just sort of hovering
around the shoulders popping up here and
there blowing people to smithereens and
you'll be well on your way to playing a
solid pharah for sure and i guess the
last big tip for me is when you're on
maps that are you know they've got a
point a lot of those are internal with
buildings with quite high ceilings jump
up there use the right click to float
around and if you can you know get
justice to rain from above uh in those
situations you're on to a winner you
might get yourself up play the game yeah
play the games come pretty frequently by
far have fun playing pharah folks and
stay tuned to gamespot for more of our
overwatch tips
all right we're gonna try again
maybe
we'll go to camera here
as we uh try to get in
um i feel like this is one of those
situations guys and gals if you find a
way to get in
do not log off because i feel like this
is like diablo 3 all over again error
33. if you're in don't freaking log off
and if you're not uh you know we'll keep
playing the let's spam
battlenet as like
the millions of other people
are probably spamming this is suddenly
kind of different but not really
it's fake this out a couple times mike
where it does the like
yeah just keeps trying what
this is the longest it's hovered on
connecting to battlenet though that's
good
no
come on
overwatch one time also guys just want
to point out if we don't get this going
today we are kind of doing
a like mini marathon of overwatch
streaming tomorrow uh we're going to
start i think at 10 a.m with um danny
and i think chris and then they're gonna
kind of pass the torch to a couple other
people in the office to you and jake and
then i think i'm the last stint it's
like me and mary
with uh maybe scott like subbing in for
mary at some point potentially so we'll
be on a bunch tomorrow
um self plug i'll be on a bunch tonight
assuming it works um so hopefully you
know it works because a lot of people
want to play this game and it's actually
i don't know maybe that open beta test
wasn't
like as clearly it's not as stressful as
like an actual release but i thought
they would have a good gauge yeah
exactly so i thought what would happen
is you know you would have
um some people
you know getting in right and then other
people either being stuck in a queue or
something and then you know obviously
still being salty and upset that they're
not in but
usually you know if you take wow for
example or whatever usually they kind of
start to adjust their servers and go
okay let's batch people in like yeah
like phase people in or whatever yeah we
haven't i don't see anyone on twitter
that has gotten in everybody's
complaining it has jokes yeah
i my whole twitter feeds just blowing up
with people going showing overwatch
servers
connection
which is nothing but pictures of that so
i can throw another video all right
let's throw up another video let me go
to the camera while you search for that
one
um the junkrat one is in the works it's
not um it's not available yet anybody
see all right all right so what we
played a mccree and a pharah so we
should probably play like a tank or a uh
or or
lucio i like listening oh we're doing a
lucio hey what's up daniel dwyer here
with more tips for overwatch chris
waters i feel like lucio was one of the
characters that people picked the least
uh but he's also one of the most
effective the audio medic as it were is
capable of doing quite a lot on the
battlefield chris let's break it down
tell me all about lucio lucio is my man
and i think the reason some people shy
away from him is one of the most
powerful things you can do as lucio is
just be around your team his passive
ability which is to heal anyone within
line of sight is super valuable for
pushing payloads for keeping teams alive
for you know being on points and really
you just have to be near people uh of
course you can switch from healing to
the speed the speed is uh i would say
more of a situational thing your default
should be healing yeah yeah all the time
speed used probably mostly at the start
of maps right at the start of maps when
you respawn also once your team is
healed up you know you can give them
that little mid-match sort of juicing
but let's talk about healing because
this is still his most important that's
okay all right guys keep watching
apparently a lot of people saying ps4 is
working so we'll try to
is super good for saving teammates and
you want to keep an eye on those
silhouettes and those critical health
bars overwatch is great at signaling to
you how your teammates health is doing
you want to respond to that as lucio and
it's probably easier to use him in terms
of other healers because he just kind of
heals everyone around him it's not like
you have to be so so worried about your
positioning and what about his ults when
should you kick that in just whenever it
comes around or in specific situations
so his alt throws down these huge shield
buffs for anyone again in eyesight and
it's great for countering a team push or
when you are trying to push in on
something uh it can also help you if uh
pharah is rocketing down on you or
there's an or you're
all right apparently pc works too uh
chris is in we are in
let's do it
oh you want to mute that other video so
lucio can get him in they're not pretty
easy he's gotta
kill that video
all righty
here we go over watch all right get get
jay hey
little abney get that get the river doge
all right
all right i know some of you guys are
watching probably gonna take off that's
all good enjoy yourself some overwatch
the people are who chilling
cool cool
all right
oh wait it looks that way the default
thing yeah all right let's just get in
we back in that poverty life mike yeah
we ain't got no skins we got nothing
nah do do do quick play let's go let's
go
all right poverty life you say yeah
poverty life man no skins no gold
i'm really hoping my like bugged out
beta gold somehow makes it that would be
the dream i'd be able to afford oh i
didn't even check legendary or uh is it
legendary is gold legendary
boy
i thought gold's epic okay so i need a i
would have an epic skin right off the
bat if i if they carried over but i
doubt it
it's a lot i'll be my main
all right you going zarya yeah ooh
someone took um
76. oh they took justin's go-to yeah i
know justin i don't think justin plays
anybody else
oh he's double tanking all right just
kidding if you heard that justin yeah he
probably didn't hear that
we are strong
where's gb at we want to snipe stream
snipe the gb
i need the chat to tell me
what their battle net id is and then
we'll try to like infiltrate their game
i don't know that's that's a kind of a
long shot but you never know
all right guys if uh between me and mike
we have a pretty good handle on a good
amount of the roster
mike's going to play for a while and
then maybe i'll switch in but if you
guys have uh you're better with like
reaper than i am so i want to show some
different yeah so i mean like if you
guys have some character requests we'll
try to do our best we're not
um
great at every character unfortunately
like i'm not that great at genji like he
can be really strong if you're like good
with him but like it's one of those
things where yeah the one that like the
toughest character that i'm good with is
mccree yeah not as good with widowmaker
as like danny or something yeah
all right here's another thing do you
think there's day one scrubs or are we
playing like legit people it's probably
some combination
oh hot kool-aid getting in this aka mary
kish but we'll have to get her next game
because uh she wasn't in the queue
already
oh watch out to your life or something i
think she's to your left now to your
right or whatever
stop backseat game if you guys have
questions
i will try to do my best to answer them
goob is also playing
day one scrubs for the first week that
would be the dream
yeah right
move that payload
yeah so it seems like
it
i will say you know so far no lag or
anything like that so if anything there
was just a delay on booting up like
spinning up all the servers or something
because it did seem like everyone in
chat was saying oh yeah it's up on ps4
up on xbox and as i was running to grab
the ps4 chris was like
there's that origins edition reaper yeah
that mercenary one
all right
that guy changed characters real quick
so
clearly wasn't
too keen on keeping his uh
super
i probably just wasted that shield on
oh did he pin
someone adam
what
about that
is getting wrecked by justin though yeah
i thought i got him i kind of assumed
that last one would kill him
damn
i'll say zarya ain't nobody like
sebastian right
zarya is probably my favorite character
in the game she's the weirdest blend of
different classes
yeah she's she's pretty good at range
she's got you know because she's got her
alternate fires
um watch out for el reaperino
oh okay so he doesn't have his reaper
walk he's really vulnerable right now if
you can finish him off oh he got away
so you use her left click as a shorter
range one right yeah it's also like
damn it it's also um
yeah it's good for short range
it doesn't have it's got like five feet
on it it's actually pretty powerful
obviously like her whole thing is if she
absorbs damage she does more damage but
all right so i got my alt which is good
because i really like her all right yeah
it would be good to get like chris with
a combo if he has alts or um
yeah not too many people you have on
your team oh uh pharah would be pretty
good too from death from above
chris is doing what he should be as
tracer
annoying the other team
uh looks like mary might have got in
which is cool
uh oh we got a korean name there you
know that they're good at the
the vidja games the esports
bastion camping already hey man it's his
job a lot of people are not happy about
the play of the game fashions but it
happens i'm curious if they yep i just
saw yeah
it's a sixty dollar game no pay to win
it's not actually sixty dollars it's 40.
uh there's guys here right so just be
careful
riverdale's got him hopefully there's
one more to your right i think it might
have been reaper
oh good night oh that's close
no uh ultimate for you reaper
let's move this up
but yeah if anything um we didn't get to
see the microtransactions maybe we'll
check that out later i don't know if
they're even in yet uh there was an
article earlier on gamespot that was
saying that [ __ ] blizzard wasn't sure
you know what they're gonna do
oh man he just got two took out your dps
ooh great alts by the mercy
um he's just sitting there waiting to
ask him for it yeah nice
oh thank you
oh my god
man that reaper is day one i have to say
yeah he's kind of going in on you guys
like all willy nilly and you really
don't want to be doing that with rupert
you kind of want to flank around pick
off the healers pick off the squishies
um
and then kind of use
yeah
you can always uh you can use the emojis
or the not the emojis but the uh the
wheel the communication wheel to tell
people you have your alt oh [ __ ] like
right there it might be decent but i
don't know
guys get in
the whole team
uh he's behind that pillar [ __ ] that
sucked it's all right now whatever might
as well use it yeah zarya is really good
for the uh
wombo combos oh yeah i want to watch out
for that
nice
he's kind of wasted his all
twice now the reaper
oh [ __ ] that's his arm yeah
trying my best to monitor chat we're
looking at three chats right now
um game spot twitch and youtube thank
you guys for watching again mike is
currently playing uh eric here just
chatting with you guys
that's when uh justin should uh just
straight up pin him to the wall
oh yeah may
make america great
um
oh you gotta is that a widow now
yep yeah i got that shield back [ __ ] i'm
not i could go around the side but
okay
pretty pretty decent play here but she's
exposed
oh bastional
yep yep yep
get down there oh again someone get me
thank you
oh he's just out oh wow your whole team
is getting pushed back though
oh nice the dublin oh
no you're good you're good you're still
getting healed by the mercy uh watch out
for the bear trap though
there you go thank you
don't want to do too much backseat
gaming but sometimes you know you just
wait to see some stuff
get in there
all right looks like
oh great
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh it's the may alt
really good for stopping um these kind
of pushes on the payload just really
holds off the team but unfortunately the
other team didn't have a follow-up it's
high noon
i think that ice wall might oh watch out
jumper at all
damn it
oh
we're back the mercy alt will it help
you guys seal the deal here
[ __ ] thank you guys
oh he's one shot
oh flashbang damn it that's all right
you have your alt yeah
we got close
yeah that that red seemed like it would
have been pretty good because i think it
should have got like three or four you
got more than me
um
but yeah hopefully uh they're like
really close to the uh end point here
yeah
we'll also see because like normally you
play both sides we'll see if you guys
will play both sides on this one i think
it depends on the uh
give him the business mike
[ __ ] that widow up there
oh [ __ ] uh they're not none of them are
live at all
yeah maybe
uh you got chris going up you got high
noon coming though
oh
damn it oh did you just all oh wow he
just got a triple that could be potgs
all
justin had to do is turn to the right
and it would have stopped all of it yeah
but that's hard to see i don't yeah but
we kind of we're looking over there
there might be a space coop a lot to see
after this i don't know how many people
joined the game
oh man it's gonna be a nail biter it
looks like
let's go this way
uh yeah you guys should
technically should try to group up
though for sure
watch out
oh that mercy just hit me
behind you
watch out junker adults come in
come in hats
oh someone killed it
that's a male 1 she only used it on one
person though
good annoyance by the maze though right
now yeah
double may is not fun
oh no it was looking so good mike
oh chris going diva
he wants to get in on that point nice
oh they're smart they started pushing
the load back
well that was weird you somehow blew up
the concussion mine didn't even know you
could do that yeah uh junkrat all
don't see it don't see it
all right
all or nothing who will win
[ __ ]
mae is one of the most infuriating
people one of my favorite characters
good i like playing with her butch she's
like a fashion yeah usually if you get a
triple you're going to probably get
played the game
damn that dude is whooping y'all i don't
know which one i don't think we're
contesting we
got to get in there
overtime is
oh no someone's there
got no that one's not i
yeah i mean this is a very team-based
game you know you need good offense as
much as you do need good tanks and
whatnot but um
oh wow he must have got like a quad or
something
yeah cause that high noon was good
yeah dead eye was good
oh there's me oh that was the revive
oh does he get like more here is that
why
i think the high noon was better to be
honest vote for me oh yeah you
are you like the uh self-voter yeah i
see gotcha i do that sometimes no not
really i actually uh i'm kind of happy
with my performance there for the most
part
no not really i died too much for a tank
it's not totally your fault though you
need to get healed oh did you get a loot
box already bam level two 20 exp in a
group should i check out if my gold came
over i don't think it would i don't
think it would either
uh you can cancel that really quick and
get goob and open your box and stuff if
you want to
and then check your box yeah i swear you
better not get a reaper skin i'll kill
you no gold
what will he get
he got a tracer skin not bad
not bad not a character you play a lot
though so not great anymore i didn't get
anything from anybody i play a lot
yeah that happened to me a lot
but i feel like in a way like they
conspiracy theory in me thinks that like
they do that so that you learn and want
to play other characters like because
like if you have a good skin you're kind
of more motivated right to play another
character
also double-sided
coin because i you wanna
get the stuff for the characters you're
really attached to and the ones that you
like but
it does sort of help encourage playing
other things i guess yeah someone got a
new profile uh chris
for the swarm baby
zerg life even though i played terran
tearing it up
is a
fun map
i think my favorite map is gibraltar
whatever
see how it goes i'm not the best with
him all right
so you got kind of like double snipes
right now with you and widowmaker
in a way i like it's weird not having to
reload with because i'm like
yeah reloading is such a oh goop said
you could play yeah it's too late
oh i thought he might take no i was just
messing with you goob i'll i'll play
hanzo
to beat you this game i'll play whoever
um sweet
junkrat is fun though he's one of my
favorites
yeah jimmy uh our kind of like tech guy
thinks that he's the easiest character
in the game because you just kind of
spam left click
i just i just can't be but if you want
to be really good with him you can you
can use his like barrett trap or his uh
his mind really well yeah especially to
disrupt tanks
it's all subjective
i really should have got giant palms
battle tag before this
so we could try to attempt to snipe them
or play with them
they got a hanzo over there too
watch out they got a junker hanging oh
watch out there lucio's kind of chilling
oh right on the back
nice
i'm getting way too close with him
oh well
mary was kind of healing yeah
i mean if you're
you've got good aim man hanzo is very
deadly
don't forget to use that map hack the
sonar yeah
that those that arrow actually does
decent damage on its own too nice shot
you got there hanzo you know what it is
i think i've been playing i was playing
ps4 for such a long time the beta just
to because that was there we go
killed your brother genji yeah
i love the dialogue between them when
they're
in the short
no like in the game too oh yeah just a
little incidental stuff yeah
ooh
are you gonna yuga tekiwaka
go f yourself
oh my god oh that was i feel like um i
don't know why you get all all four of
them look they're standing in a row
you don't want to do it
is that you uh did you get anyone
nope nope got a mccree though
you scared them that would have been
definitely scared they've been stuck
here for a while if not i think i'll get
a lot more chances yeah
oh watch out now they're doing it
oh don't forget that armor too to your
right oh what's down one stone double
tank their soldier altered or someone
yeah they're soldier altered
they're yeah they're blowing all their
alts right now yeah i think you might be
one of the last ones left so just know
that
oh
i'm sorry
thug mastered
pop your head out mccree damn it nope
nope he missed
oh
you're doing real well there like 10
kill streak i think i think so
yeah
they find me they're on with hanzo or
off with hanzo
it's funny it's really ugly when i'm off
and they finally got the payload like in
their speed though
yeah you can do those uh wall runs or
whatever climb wall climbs him against
you both
i actually should stay at the top
oh i hear roadhog
there goes widowmaker oh nice shot
save your birth keep running no
is that my widow or yeah that is your
widow
he just hooked you up
with um with the map hacks i want you to
do your mind and you just do the alt
right now get in the business
that is the most terrifying thing
or you could amand up and try to shoot
him in the head yeah right have a
mexican
what is it mexican standoff or whatever
i probably butchered that sorry guys ooh
your brother came for vengeance i like
genji a lot i've been playing him more
often recently or before the bait ended
you know what i i think you did that i
that i uh do too with hanzo is i kind of
aim the alt too far
you know what i mean because it it it
takes some time to wind up right
so like
i had a wall right in front of me and
what is still true yeah i think so i
think what you want to do i think
because i'm not a great hands-on
player either but like you know like
because you shot it more at a distance
it take it's like almost like the
beginning of the start-up for that
whereas like damn that if you shot it a
little bit more towards the ground or
something i think it would have
yeah anyways who knows we'll find out
you'll probably get another one
you got that pretty quickly all things
considered because they only got damaged
yeah it only got to like one point on
that one i
think
i thought that soldier 76 was still up
here
nah he died
oh he should be flashbanging wow that
was not a matchup i wanted
oh there's that song that guy's on fire
man
i give him credit he was the only one he
did some single shots before the uh fan
in the hammer
i am surprised he didn't try to
flashbang though because i feel like you
almost i'm still kind of far away in the
first song like you have to be within a
few feet i mean it's got an aoe on it
but that's true
plus like it's almost like a last
defense sometimes too even it's good for
initiating attacks but i use it as kind
of getting get out of jail free card
thing
oh jay hey that was a crazy move
got one
oh don't you do this to me
you hit him didn't kill him now
got some armor from our good buddy river
doge oh watch out soldiers assaulted
in that scatter business yeah
you would have thought that would have
hit more people
oh mary's like one shot
oh yeah mixed fusion eat an arrow
oh
damn it no
he tried the hero alt
it did not work
it's okay we still have the alt
for the next stopping of the payload
there
that would have been pretty sick if you
could have got that off that would have
been a good looking pog well hopefully
we'll still we're still going to get it
right here we're still going to get this
prtg right here they're all crowded they
just want that payload
so we're going to throw a scatter shot
on there oh right here
yeah just right through it
are they there oh that's one oh shoot
he's he's an angry winston
oh he's got you in a corner
i only have one person it looked like i
was damaging other people
you want to do that ideally from like
the front of their line to the back i
kind of went through the side yeah
well also like the uh either the
widowmaker alt or uh your uh little
pulse thing ran out so you couldn't see
him anymore yeah that was a widowmaker
this is a tough point for them to push
through though because you spawn so
close
so
uh i think that you should be able to
hold as long as they don't get too crazy
where is he it's making me he killed one
he killed uh chris
um that's it
they definitely have a good
push coming though
i think their whole team's alive too
which is a problem
damn boxes right there watch out here
you got revived
hopefully oh great all by the opposing
lucio we're probably gonna push through
here unless one of your tanks gets on it
you gotta get there quick
oh you guys dropped the b2 someone's got
to get on the payload
spot
they can't just be chilling
you have all
i believe in you
you got two beauty
nice
hanging on by a thread oh yeah like the
quad push it back the pseudo quad
oh yeah just racking them up
i did not even see that person just kind
of feathered one in there i was aiming
for the winston over there and then i
killed a lucio or a soldier
oh there we go lucio
damn it no i'm going over here
oh watch out for winston
charlton i don't know i don't think so
actually oh [ __ ]
good read
that kind of helps them and
nice
all right you got alt again for later
yeah the winston's just trying to
disrupt you guys to get off the payload
as long as one of you guys is on the
point you guys oh here we go
potg
oh come on that's two
just gotta clear the rest of these guys
so they don't get back
oh goodnight lucio
yeah all right yeah i think we got it
yeah what a hold do we think you got
potg here no i think i don't think so
there was like two right there right
yeah but that other one was a pretty
solid hold
pretty consistent overall
got some good hanzo kills yeah that's
right play the game
there's gotta be that last one right
yeah
well i get to show that lucy okay i get
right after this
depends
yeah right at the last second
that's how you do it how did you knock
it on the list though no i think it was
just because they didn't want to put
kills up here because this was yeah
we did it
some torbjorn recognition
a lot of silver medals rank three
got another box
that was a really strong hold it was it
was like right there
i'm gonna open that quick do it
are you gonna get some chris waters luck
some legendary or epic off right off the
bat no
oh you you gotta or is that victory pose
that's not bad that's the character you
play at least you know so that's good
uh lucio oh man i'm gonna miss my sick
reaper
win pose
the one where he does the like kind of
like you know puts his thumb at the neck
and then drops he drops his guns pretty
good soldier i can't preview those two
um that happens sometimes i'm not really
sure why
i guess jay haye has stopped oh he has
his uh monday night thing
to do oh look randolph ramses is playing
overwatch i don't know if he's coming in
i just saw him on the oh dub
um
why don't you try another
another hero
genji or mccree i don't know what you
show me your mccree
show me that skill
yes the game is out today it was uh up
at i guess we'll say 4 19 almost 420
because
it wasn't the servers weren't up yet i
think at four but it did release
technically at four
um we'll get er depending on how he
plays we can try the genji but um
i don't know it's up to him
uh
yeah at some point
i hear a genji already
yeah so we're probably not doing a
double genji at this point
what's up hjp one in the twitch chat
welcome welcome
also hello to all the youtube
chat people and the game spot chat
thanks for watching
um this is our third
i guess game match uh we are currently
one and one
the close uh first loss
that's a pretty good one tyler mcmullen
in youtube chat saying they miss an
opportunity to make the servers go live
at high
noon yeah you got to get rid of that
uh mercy so that winston stops giving
you guys
oh yeah
oh
bad fan that camera no i got her anyways
it's all right
good needs to switch off of that speed
buff and get you some
oh he's still behind you
got him nice
yeah it's kind of like the gun is pretty
good if you have you know good aim
because it gives you nerfed it right
since like before the game first came
out yeah it was really good on long
range
it's still pretty good though man
it feels like a deagle in the counter
striker from like mid-range oh [ __ ]
tracer though she's a nightmare with him
oh i mean up close you smell yeah but
all you gotta do is flashbang fan the
hammer and it's like kind of a good
night
this point can be pretty hard
nice head shot there mike i
you knew she was coming down you know
you preemptively
kind of
had [ __ ] is that their
said you played hanzo amazing hanzo
amazingly so [ __ ] give me a shout out
for that
all right that winston clearly doesn't
know that he got revived or something or
his afk
oh damn it
i had my
i couldn't have used that either way too
no there was only one person in front of
you so it's fine
back into the mix
he walks really slowly yeah that's his
kind of like one thing may alt
and a hanzo alt
right they tried to do the wombos
i don't know you guys look to begin
there we go
that's easy enough let's get in there
looks like you're gonna be fine [ __ ] oh
yeah that's not a good move that's not a
good look
you can't be doing that you should have
been waiting on the next point or
something
can't see it's nice
nice alt
oh not
yeah you want dexter reaper wants you to
round the corner and use high noon but
uh he needs he needs to yeah he needs
more targets like
now which might be okay
four people in there oh yeah here we go
here we go here we go
where are they
god damn it they all died
yeah at least it only eats up fifty
percent yeah that's not terrible on one
dude
is that ours what's up gmack you know
from australia hope you're having a
happy overwatch day hope you're all
having a happy overwatch day either
watching or playing
mercy's
[ __ ]
thanks i am ian dizzeon713 said good
teamwork i think that was for the last
map
watch out uh soldiers pop these old god
damn it oh chris with a triple
i don't even know what you could do
there except maybe combat roll and hope
that like
that's a triple for the hanzo that could
be potg who knows
great role
do a barrel roll
would be funny if i actually rolled into
a barrel
is that amazing
they are all over there yeah
it's [ __ ]
oh no you had one skull
jerks oh i almost had him
who will win
oh
that's he's that's a losing that's a
loser
that's uh he's never gonna win oh right
here
oh not a single one wow
watch out for the mail
flash give him the fan the hammer
get out of there damn it dog rolled into
the wall
you've been pummeled by winston i know
he's the same dude playing him
you don't really see we've been seeing a
lot of winston's compared to 1 52 a.m in
hamburg germany thanks for tuning in
damn that get anybody i want to sound
like yeah
it's it's definitely easier for him when
he's in close quarters obviously that
was a winston oh yeah fan it already
i just saw that
this mouse the wire's getting caught is
it i'd have to pull the computer closer
to you
whoa
someone's aggressive calm people
imbeciles
in the business
oh
rip to night road
the man's on fire
yeah that's pretty good
oh that was nice he led it
soldier oh good i need another but i
think chris just
it or sounded like it
mmm that may icicle snipe i like it
oh yeah he just defaulted
and he got
is that us that's them i think if i uh
remember
the opposing team oh we're doing a
little sneaky sneak trying to get behind
with this little old flanker
oh hello bastion
on that roll bro
don't scare me like that man
i'm like i thought i really was sleeping
in the hammer
what's up i'm gonna butcher this name
i'm sorry family
um thank you for your
appreciation
okay it's high noon boys and girls will
he get one this time
he's gonna not get one
oh rip did you grab that help
oh yeah
uh question from wwe diva for life do
you find yourself getting better with
the more matches you play i think so i
think if you kind of
hone um
you know one of each type of uh hero
it'll be really beneficial for you so
you can kind of fill out the roles that
your team might need
and also
um you know
just try to play you know some of those
characters you like
and then just kind of commit to it if
you don't feel like it's your play style
or whatever you know try mixing it up
that's the beauty of overwatch you can
change characters at any time yeah so
you know definitely figure out which
characters you like
yeah you can play against bots as well i
believe so all right self-destruct why
would that winston go towards it
oh he died still
oh this is all you
never
prayed to kill me i don't think we
needed to pray there
uh watch out hanzo
right down the lane
okay here we go here we go i'm just i'm
killing yep dude oh i could have gotten
three if i waited i didn't want that
that's fine you gotta you gotta take it
sometimes
oh that guy's asking for trouble don't
come in on a mccree like that
congrats your high note is consistent
yeah we gotta we gotta kill that time
though all right good stalling by may
here i like it
i think it's over though yeah good good
game
ggs
um pretty solid game not not amazing but
pretty solid you know when a win is a
win w's a w yeah
this one this is a triple i think
oh he did that right away
oh is it gonna be a quad
no it's a triple unless he
no it was a good triple though it
cleared the point
that was a beauty nice job chris waters
epic
wow the bastion 28
okay that's that's the kind of funny
thing about like when you play an
opposing team they just kind of try to
find the person on their team that did
something good and they're like nah we
ain't we're giving the other team credit
unless you know unless it was like
really spectacular then then maybe you
get some
what's up get in boty so kind of like
almost like booty but not um
hello hello uh glad you're tuning in
from denmark
if anything we know that your high needs
at least scared people away
i guess all right you got torbjorn logo
you can get out of that
day one overwatch logo life
if you so choose
awesome map we'll try to find those
arrows and stuff from the short they're
supposed to be in it right
like
uh the what the the arrows from the
short they're in there yeah yeah yeah
oh drunk rap
who knows how much dlc they're gonna add
in the future who knows it's too hard to
say i would imagine like maybe character
packs or something
like four at a time or something maybe
who knows it's too hard to speculate
that
i will say though it's like in seeing
one of the older kind of mock-ups uh
like poster type things there were
characters that aren't in this game so i
wouldn't be surprised if maybe some of
those get reworked and put into this one
playing some junk right here those
shorts um
in the wind the first short the winston
one
showed like he was activating overwatch
agents and there were like a few people
in the computer screen that are not in
the game nice
looking forward to those
functions
but we got 21 fun characters we can play
nice
yeah christopher um you're gonna have to
send your info to mike or send it to me
on um
in the twitch chat and i will try to get
mike to invite you next game
high noon is the scariest time of the
day i agree crazy on i do agree knowing
there's someone out there that needs to
be blown up
i don't disagree with that statement
junkrat
ooh chris is playing his symmetra
he plays a pretty mean symmetra
she's pretty pivotal in in the games as
well her teleporter can be key
um
to get you back to the point sooner
obviously
all right this winston's got some traps
oh he said screw your traps i'm going
for the point
oh wow he murked chris
all right you guys got him
foreign
nice
oh nice
geocooker just got cooked
are they on the point it sounds like
they're contesting it to me
oh hello pharah
oh man my health was low yeah i wasn't
telling you to get health but i thought
you saw it
man
is there a campaign mode in overwatch
there is not um so far there's quick
play
i think at some point competitive mode
will make its way back in there's also
that kind of like weekly brawl which
kind of swaps out your character
um you're kind of locked into a
character
which is pretty good it's a good way to
learn because you kind of get forced to
play you know hero that you don't
necessarily know and you know other
players are in the same kind of boat
they are on the point
oh double tank in there though
oh look at chris going in like a boss
all right it's all right
the second point is pretty hard to to
get into so hopefully you guys can
defend
we're going for a triple you're gonna
die probably though
oh and they killed it that's unfortunate
the same hanzo damn
he's like oh look a free kill
that's kind of some bad luck
i probably shouldn't have done that that
close to them but
didn't take him all that long
uh sachin asking favorite characters so
far
for me
it's probably
yeah that's a tough one i really enjoy
playing mei
um
reaper as well
uh what about you mike who are your kind
of like zarya
i like mccree a lot
and
lucio maybe
yeah uh lucy is probably my favorite
healer as well
um
in terms of server somebody asking about
servers how they're holding up they're
fine we had troubles logging in which it
seemed like most people were having
but once you once we got in no problem
we are good
um
yeah
will they be adding new game was in the
future again not sure about that uh the
only ones that we know of uh is
competitive mode
uh that's the one that's not in there
right now
the most op ulti i think that's really
kind of subjective it's like situational
i think they're all pretty good the
reapers can be pretty devastating
i mean you can yeah you can argue kind
of like mine right rip tire can be
pretty
mess people up too yeah
hey what's our favorite map i think you
said gibraltar right
i like uh purple sky industries yeah i
kind of like
nepal and i like oh no i think i like
lee jiang tower more in terms of like
that kind of kind of game mode
yeah they're all kind of in that like
smaller area for the the capture points
they're on your point right now oh [ __ ]
why don't you play together guys um just
so you know one of us can be kind of
chatting with you guys asking questions
we want to do some interaction we don't
want to leave you guys hanging
um because you know some people are
asking questions
get wrecked by the uh suicide bombs
i don't use winston much at all
should use this but not enough of them
around the point this point's actually
easy to get retired kills most of the
time because they're kind of
watching every direction
no idea if japanese voices are available
i mean i think genji and hanzo use
the language but um
i don't know if you can change the
language it'd be pretty cool i'd i
think
it'd be pretty awesome to hear them all
in japanese but i would assume that it's
not the case
is overwatch two player and no it's uh
six players on one team i don't think
you can split screen right not even on
console
i don't think so
how many maps are there ah that's a good
question that i don't have an answer to
unfortunately sorry about that um
i got into the quote or open beta later
and there was like a couple maps i
didn't play so
it's hard for me to say i want to say is
it 10 maps i think because did we get
like 10 okay i think there you go
no worries
there aren't any new characters right
now uh oh i'm being told 12 maps 21
characters three game modes thank you
for that information i know it's like
four game modes well there's the hybrid
one
there's a hybrid mode attack defend
um and payload payload yeah but then
isn't it just this no but there's one
there's one where you're and then the
there's one where you're both battling
over the
that king of the hills four game modes
okay if you count the hybrid
bam seo winston
oh he altered by the way yeah
he's going just
he's flailing about
zenyatta
experience the tranquility
is it on xbox yet it should be it's uh
on all three platforms ps4 xbox one pc
they all pretty much went live server
wise at the same time like i said
earlier there were some problems but now
that we're in no problems i do not know
if people are
continuing to have problems logging in
but we've been able to everyone that we
know in the office that have kind of
joined in or whatnot hasn't seemed to
have a problem getting in
yes the roster is the same currently as
the open beta
a lot of the game in open like the open
beta is pretty much more or less what
you're getting currently right day one
seems like yeah pretty much um yeah
again the only thing we're waiting for
like uh that we know that we're waiting
for is the competitive mode which is
probably being reworked and whatnot
uh there aren't more maps than beta
benito
it's the same
damn there's a wait over there
yeah this point is really hard to break
if the team is not coordinated and
whatnot
um but we'll see they they still got a
lot of time they they got the first
point pretty quickly
so basically on this team like when
you're on offense trying to get the
point you want to try to use characters
that can go to the other side which
there is a junkrat over there
oh this is a perfect spot for you
as he charged oh you're in trouble
oh that was unfortunate too your bombs
fell off the side yeah i don't think he
was going to stave her for very long but
it would have been funny if your uh your
mind had
you know how punted the reinhardt if
that somehow got him a pin
uh i don't think there's been any
balance changes since that beta
currently that i know of
i do not believe there's cross-platform
play
um as mike said there's not because they
don't even have that in like there's no
battle net or whatever really for um
for console it's like diablo
but uh maybe you'll at least have the
semi dream if they ever do it where you
can play xbox and ps4 or whatever
wow i'm surprised i didn't kill him
yeah you still unlock things through
leveling up um and getting loot crates
we haven't checked if there's micro
transactions at all yet
i don't know how you still got him with
that
seemed like he was already gone
i mean homage claude if you feel like
it's overhyped and overpriced obviously
you don't have to buy it but again this
game you can get for 40 dollars which i
think if you enjoy playing this game you
have you know friends that play the game
it's gonna definitely enhance your
experience it is a very team-based
shooter
um
but yeah it's you know definitely not
for everybody you know um
but
in some of our opinions we we enjoy
sorry yeah we should be good they take
yeah it takes a while for them yeah
they're gonna get one more push uh it's
is it really 60 on console as well
there's no normal edition is it only is
there only a normal edition for uh pc
i thought it was 40 and then it was 60
for origin but you know i'd have to look
up the prices for sure i mean i think
this game's worth 60 bucks anyway but
yeah again like it's
there's a lot of factors to that though
right so i mean to each their own for
sure
will there be a lot more skins
i mean i wouldn't doubt it but who knows
like
um
i think you guys got it here yeah this
point is so hard to break if they're not
coordinated
victory
again pretty solid game there mike you
know
nothing much going on fancy but you know
you still gotta play the game how and
maybe none of us really did too well i
don't feel like oh this this one's
pretty good you got like a triple right
did you get the mercy here at the end
you got the detonation in the mercy yeah
did you get the mercy here so yeah you
got a triple there just must have been
not that much going on
yeah
fair enough no idea
still didn't make that uh the cards
though objective kills
does overwatch have a ranking system or
something yeah it'll have
yeah i have competitive mode and i think
that has like a
large
type of ranking system
if you want to get more you know like
hardcore into it yeah
uh tay do you want to jump on uh sure
all right switch
stuff
all right all right so tay's playing now
he's gonna
get some experience for my account oh
yeah i just realized that damn it
well feel free to log out oh no as long
as
as long as you're uh not as long as you
don't get like a skin
that i want then i won't be triggered
but if you have i'm not even gonna look
at the boxes because it's just gonna put
me on tilt if there's like a skin i want
our review our review and progress is up
right now uh our review will be
likely in a couple days just to make
sure we get 48 hours before we
i think the game's stable
this week 100
i think mvp maybe gives you like a
little bit more points right towards
like experience levels
i think well i mean like if you're doing
well generally it's going to give you a
slight bump in
leveling but i think you had told me
it's not like this huge difference
though i don't think so i think someone
did the math and the metals
it's not a huge
the game's not completely contingent on
how well you perform it helps but it's
not a huge deal from what i understand
attack commences in 30 seconds all right
let's shake off the rust of not playing
for like
how long has it been since open bay like
two weeks maybe
oh we should have looked at the arcade
games my bad guys oh they all they blew
them all up
oh they're all just damaged goods now we
can't watch
i can't look at some of these hot games
like
super siege mode three and lost biking
six
and vb's adventure
all right so we got double tanks
one healer
what happened to my healer
oh she died
man
i should have just ran
instead of going to fight him
i gotta try to sneak up on him
hope he's just kind of like yeah nope
oh
jesus
yeah he got me his eyes
is reaper your go-to um sort of but uh
i'm definitely not showing that right
now i almost got sniped by he he did
what he's supposed to do there just wait
for me um but i couldn't there wasn't i
guess i could have just teleported away
and just not have dealt with that i mean
considering
he's not even at the point like we
should just go capture it yeah i feel
like
i can make like a crazy play and just
like
teleport past everyone
see ya
all right
we'll see if they come back here or if
we just play the objective game
hot capture
you guys know that i'm capturing are you
guys having a nice death match out there
oh my god she's so close to dying i'm
gonna stand the point
oh though matchup for him
mercy's helping you out
got alt too
i'm gonna get to that corner spot that i
was talking about maybe the mercy
follows me she did not
see if we can be a nuisance here
okay we gotta jump right up
oh that widow's really close
i'm gonna go get this held
gotta play a little smarter those check
me out that was pretty upsetting though
yeah
it's kind of a tease
oh my god that was well played by him i
don't know if he purposely launched
himself watch
but i don't
know oh there you go
oh man he's got another one ready for
you
oh
nice
away for now
someone get on very nice
i need to like teleport somewhere else
tay what's your favorite ultimate have
you said that yet uh i haven't um
hold on sorry
um i don't know i mean i like reapers
because i oh we won i think they can
push us off here
jump right alt though
i'd have to go with
dang that wasn't give me this kill
die
uh my favorite all is probably i don't
know i really like zarya's you pretty
much create a chokepoint divas is pretty
great nice chris
uh yeah divas can clear points soldier
76 is pretty
great too
yeah it's pretty much like aimbot right
yeah
oh that was a good
good save there on the uh the trap
yeah um
i like reapers a lot um
i like seeing zarya's kind of like wombo
combo with other stuff so like
especially when you're playing with the
team
um yeah yeah
all right looks like i got you a box
sweet
we should try to get rob cat in here oh
yeah i'm supposed to add a cj fant as
well
let's see if i can do that real quick
hopefully i'm leader and i can kind of
like
grab that guy
and grab rob here
maybe nope i'm just going straight into
baby
rob just try to follow us
uh i'll play may here
get some some variants and characters
we gotta make america great
with a k yeah
all right we got robin that's good
rob's gonna go with this uh bastion yeah
probably on attack yeah no i don't think
so really you think so yeah
unless she's listening right now oh man
i'm calling it puppy tails bastion uh we
played hanzo already uh after may i'll
play someone who's playing diva
get some may this is good i don't really
play may so
oh
look rob is expanding his
his arsenal
river dogs playing his favorite healer
the audio medic
this is an interesting comp as attacking
i don't know why we'd have a widowmaker
on attack but all right
yeah yeah well this map especially in
the middle oh man all right here we go
there's gonna be so many people over
here
oh maybe not maybe we'll just get a free
a freebie gamestop gamespot does have a
twitch we're streaming there as well
it's twitch.tv
gamespot for those asking this diva
frozer
game is not free to play it's uh
freezer again hopefully for my team
i'm going to use my shift gotta try to
help my healer
oh no he baited me but he died for it
okay
i do it for the team like
sacrifice yeah
oh i should have i wonder no i think
once you're pinned you can't press
anything
but we got the point off of that so
that's good do you use maze icicle shot
pretty often um for far for distance it
can mess people up
um especially when you freeze them like
on the non-tank characters you can kind
of get head shots pretty easily
it's pretty powerful is that good
oh that's the worst feeling nice
uh guys oh man
oh
nice wall
nice tall
these guys you just turn my team can get
in here because i just altered
yeah at least you
they could have gone so much worse
the wall is perfect where's my team
like where's my team i don't know you
were you were
pulling your weight yeah you got shot in
the face
i gotta get back in the fight
oh mary just teleported off of the map
that was hot
oh roadhog
jesus they're all in here
nice
oh lucio coming in
oh that's our lucio oh he's counter kill
him oh mega oh my god i got wrecked
dude
me and chris though trying to hold the
fort he's laying down
he just mopped the floor with me
is he still playing okay all right did
he send it in this time oh that's is
that theirs
i don't know whose that was
dude they have so many tanks
oh two of them
this isn't going so hard
but it's like i feel like it's like me
and chris on the point and then like
everyone else is like outside
who's who's playing widowmaker uh i
don't know someone that shouldn't like i
don't see why you would ever play widow
on this map mary's doing tracer so
that's fine he's like getting into the
back line and stuff but they're probably
oh [ __ ]
diva's so hard to hit out of inner pilot
form
oh
oh you altered
got out of it though luckily
come on nice
someone else kill him
uh yeah i don't know
no it was not yours oh my god good thing
you did that
stay over there
oh no middle mouse is not mapped to
freaking
my melee
normally my my middle mouse is on my
melee
so that almost threw me for a loop is it
v okay it's v
because i like to punch them when i
freeze them too yeah
those swag points
okay all right well
they have like three tanks on the other
team
oh
no
that was so unlucky
that was so unlucky i happened to peek
when he freaking charged
no
let me back in the fight
contest it
oh wait are they trying to contest our
points
all right
oh this is bad dang they've been pretty
consistent with being in there
oh she's screwed
yeah
stick it out
yeah no one else oh there's you go
there's yeah but you and lucy aren't the
best
okay come on
oh [ __ ] oh no they're everywhere
yeah you and chris are the ones getting
in there
he broke it down
are we going to lose this mic
there's still a few up there if they can
just suck it up and get in there
oh man this is close
that's theirs ours no it's you know it
was yours that was theirs i think
oh what was that oh my oh
damn that didn't look good good
this is not good
this is not good that's a bad
wow this is so weird we have one tank
i don't know man
i hope
oh god
time to yolo
oh my god that could not have gone
anywhere
it was a hook into a pin that was so bad
the dude with the hooks probably pissed
off about that
what are you doing yeah so so there's
this game mode attack and defend payload
but then there's the hybrid one so
there's kind of four
whatever you can do whatever he wants
who are you talking to i was going to
say that widow should get off a widow
but whatever
didn't really see them because i don't
think the widow like it's not going to
help you that much unless yeah see even
chris is telling
the widow because it's like unless she's
trying to snipe people coming around the
corner he says hell no
yeah clearly clearly this guy plays for
uh
he plays for kills he doesn't play for
he has 20 eliminations all right cool
bro yeah but yeah this isn't call of
duty all right whatever
nice
oh
what the hell uh
i was i thought it was like a winston on
you
oh god with the reinhardt killed him
though luckily
yeah that was my fault
i was like spamming it out of fear
because i didn't think i had it but
i did
i have to get back in the fight yeah
that's not good they're gonna get the
point i think
no chris is annoying them who's chris
playing lucio
oh god
oh hi guys
this is not awkward
come on kill the reinhardt
oh no i tried the freaking ice yeah i
tried to
ice block or whatever
hey what are you saying this is your
favorite map
yeah i think so
all right thank goodness we got another
tank oh no he just swapped
gibraltar
uh
yeah
like one of the more creative heroes
they made
oh
jesus
i'm gonna use ultimate swap i don't even
know if we'll have enough time to swap i
think we're just gonna lose this game
yeah i might have to
i don't you don't have many pure
attackers on right now i think tracer is
your offensive
all right time to go in
oh did he kill the alt
can you
do that he did yeah you can i what the
little orb before like deployed or
something yeah because i threw it out
right and it used my alt so
i don't know why like rob has to get in
there though like if you're the tank
guys
your job is to front mine
that's fine
it's okay he's still new at the game so
yeah what happens uh i can play a
zenyatta game
yeah
that wasn't such a
hot
how did he even kill her there oh i
think she fell off the map
i was playing the game
yay our sniper did so much damage
but we lost
epic
so
yeah at least the map rotation isn't
pretty
i'm
not the biggest fan of this map it's
tough oh this one might be hard as
but we'll try it
give it a go
you can go double healer zenyatta's got
some deeps
just stay in the back and just throw
your orbs
he's definitely not as cool without my
epics you see that the play of the game
you could see mary fall off the cliff
yeah see that yeah i was wondering how
the soldier killed her but i think it's
because she fell off yeah
we've got some zenyatta coming your way
don't you worry about that
i've used zenyatta one match
rob going widowmaker
wait are you attacking or defending
attacking
thank you uh the mudo might not be that
bad to pick off the other widow but it's
gonna be tough because it's only like
one spot right
um
who's going mccree no just random
all right hopefully i don't get murked
because zenyatta's health is like pretty
low yeah zenyatta is a support he can
but he does everything kind of he buffs
debuffs
heals yeah which is ultimate um called
it's like
transcendence yeah it's like uh he
becomes
invulnerable
oh that guy just got destroyed
okay is that bastion yeah it's bastion
i gotta orbit discord oh
man that's the that's the widowmaker
from last okay that guy is gonna pay
damn
it's pretty easy there though that
wasn't to be honest it wasn't a hard
shot
still shocking when it happens to you
yeah i mean like obviously like
all right this chord in him yeah
zenyatta is kind of a hybrid support
character his ultimate's the only one
come on i'm so close to killing him
dude do i even go this way i feel like
i'm just gonna get sniped
i feel like oh again
everybody gets sniped oh yeah he's still
there
it's bold of you
the orbs hoping that uh the widow will
run into it i should just switch to a
freaking tank
would you give me props if i got that
yeah
for sure
i don't think i can yeah twice a couple
of times
damn hitting her i'm hitting her this is
close
oh look at this guy
yeah that dude hasn't played up anybody
since we
yeah
ah damn our healer just died no
i have alt but it kind of doesn't matter
i was hoping chris would live so that i
could go in there and freaking heal him
but
damn it adversity is an opportunity for
change genji and him are like best
friends oh god he just got wrecked
whoever that was
yeah this is pc this point is really
hard to capture
or get through
um but there are ways around it
obviously
oh that was really dumb on my part
all right let's just go let's just go
let's go let's go
let's go no they know we're not into
that idea sick all right
good chat all right good chat guys and
girls man
luva dogs playing uh zara you both can
shield people they're kind of you can
orbit i think this is gonna work
i'll switch back to zenyatta when we can
get past this point but this is not a
good look so far i think our genji
finally broke through
oh please hit it oh
jesus
they have a teleporter yes and they have
a freaking
turret
do you think this would kill him
nope i couldn't even get it off i was
gonna try to pin him i think it would
kill do you think it would kill because
he gets like so much armor like he has
600 life i would assume i bet
on my part
not a good look chat
um
i don't know i feel like our guys pushed
forward so it was weird to me that they
were like
chilling there
damn how does he all right
no he looked through it
how does he keep is that the same
torbjorn halting i think so
come quickly friends
don't worry guys they don't seem to be
paying attention to while they uh
neither team seems to be paying
attention
forever
that torbjorn's really into getting
behind you i can't there's like they got
so many guys in like good spots damn i
don't even know if you're gonna contest
that forever i don't think so dude
it's not looking like it
like
yikes that point is really rough if
you're not like
communicating or whatever
all right we'll play one more map and
then probably call it a day all right
are you playing i don't know we'll see
what the team ends up being
that was a real bad game though
like yeah we needed this like
i don't know if he could have sniped
that from there though
we needed someone to kill that turret we
didn't have anyone to kill the turret
it's not good
uh do we have a full group now or no uh
no but i was supposed to grab goob
and then i have other friends on but
we're on your account so
let's get ed
yeah get edmond in here we'll open your
box
watch me open a legendary epic epic
give him an epic show the streaming epic
i got double blue though yeah got a
little tour
she's got some gold 50. oh did you still
not enough to get anything yet no you
could get
75. is it 75 okay i believe so unless
like sprays are 50 or something
oops
uh let's queue up oh so we can can we
look at the shop i want to work for the
shop let me see if i can
can i
browse
all right let's see what the shops like
oh yeah they're boxes
so two for two
five four five why would you have two
these two and then eleven per ten so
you're getting one extra box at ten
twenty four twenty four which is four
extra and then fifty boxes for forty so
it's just like hearthstone
dude it's fine it's i don't know it's
not something to win it's just pay to
like i know good but you still wish it
didn't make you gamble because they're
random yeah exactly that that is the
problem uh so there it doesn't look like
there was any like gold purchasing or
whatever so
all right
we're doing it
i'm gonna find a way mike to make this
work oh we're defending though
you still could yeah it's fine wait who
else did people when you play
genji i'm really bad at genji yeah
i only just started playing a lot of
genji
we have no sniper
not good at sniping either
okay some people are saying you can buy
stuff with 50 so maybe i'm thinking
i think it's just the very like kind of
basic colors though yeah
all right this is a sniper in my opinion
did you guys see me almost kill the
widowmaker
yeah we saw
i know but man so you not do
it no i know
it's true i'm just messing around it
didn't happen
that's so weird seeing shift on people
because i'm used to zarya whose shift
does it to herself so oh really yeah
okay
this is the best though
i gotta kill someone with that that
would be great he'll just get the kick
guys like monk pants on he looks like
the monk from uh you dressed like the
monk from diablo yeah which is my
favorite class
if i get someone with that that'll be uh
considered a win oh here i'll hang out
with
good old rob cat iris
robbie
yep right here over the top
i'm like sitting indian style from here
orbit discorder
she's dead to
rob
try to orbit discord down there when i
can
oh we killed freaking reinhardt we did
97 damage to him
i should get on
does discord do lowered their damage
armor or two oh shoot oh
oh oh my god
he knows oh you were so close
oh he really he watched that oh man i
should have charged it up i should have
been a man and just charged it up damn
oh my god that sucks i should have
discorded him too
that is
rather upsetting
oh of course the teleporter should i
just go back i feel like i should go
back
it's gonna be faster
100 faster
oh what did you just get me into chris
pass through the iris
don't go there rob
oh just outplayed that guy though
oh no
i was in not the best spot but that kind
of was fine i guess
i got like two kills there
just get one shot damn i didn't even
need to do that hook oh it's pretty
funny
it's all right
oh man this is such a good map for widow
and we don't have one
yeah for once you're not on a team where
the dude only plays widow
nice
i'll save you rob
whoa where's the justice
i don't think i'm healing enough i need
to try to focus more on that because
chris only shields
oh this is bad
nice
you got all of them for now
all
i knew
everyone hide
oh i think rob's dead
you playing bastion
yeah i heard high noon though
oh come on
foreign
i'm just like sitting on it
but i feel like maybe all the waste i
don't know
i don't know you guys are making a stand
here might as well use something
oh
let's drop the beat
i haven't even seen that wow there she
is
nice
yeah
oh man pog
i think you kill all three
wait it out wait out guys high noon
oh hello bear behind ferry behind
damn
that torbjorn up there
while you're
charging your shot no unfortunately not
oh crap
no oh i kicked them yeah
heel kick was sick
got her let's go nice
i wish i had alt right now for the team
get after it
yeah i think you got it
yes they come from above
yeah that fair has been doing you got it
across
i think you got it
got it yeah yeah let's go three people
get that kick
zenyatta
see how many four
one
get all
okay that's two
three
triple all right all right aye aye aye
who do we go to who do we give it to you
give it to uh
all right
all right we'll get married oh it's a
tie
two leg race here
um
23 with the zenyatta
nice 23 limbs not the highest on our
team unfortunately it was a pretty at
least it was a good
zenyatta game um what do you want to do
here
you want to play one game before we wrap
it up or i'm
i'm fine okay you want to go all right
let me tell these guys we're done for
now
yeah i'm gonna get oh
might have to attack let's go for one
more all right i guess we're attacking
guys it's the last one yeah
what should i do
you played tracer do you play tracer no
not really i don't play a good tracer
that's for sure
maybe
lucio yeah
what an audio medic
all right
come on let's bring it together
i grow tired
all right let's see what's our team comp
looking like no tanks yeah
all right there you go now there's diva
all right
we're just gonna walk out the front door
huh
[ __ ] yeah
all right this is the official last
last one since we got a shovel bro
hopefully try to oh there's a turret
there hopefully
one of the guys over here sees it
okay i think rob there's a bastion up
top too
i'm not even though i'm the healer i'm
not going out there
that's like asking for trouble
yeah screw that oh chris
oh don't talk to that mary oh she almost
died today
oh we got the flank we got the flank
yeah oh [ __ ] bastion
all right got the turret man
that guy was not
offensive lucio
no problem
uh oh someone found me
get out of there
uh i just walked on the widow making
mine uh you won't have me
this is gonna make you feel better he's
still behind you i don't know
i don't know
i love the sound the gun
oh heal you rob don't die
oh someone go up there
we can please it down but i don't feel
like we need to
um
i feel like everyone else break it down
oh [ __ ] jumper at all
all right ed took it like a champ
uh-oh
oh okay
me and you
oh did he die
no did that die i did man where the hell
is our team no idea
it's a payload
unless unless there's like unless it's
like mary tracer she's like trying to
get the back lines skirmish
all right we're we're looking better oh
fricking way over there i hear bashing
all
may over there
these guys
damn what is that doing
hey okay
you like stop moving
yeah city dc
hustler
oh my god
double tour bjorn bastian feels feels
good somebody switched to freaking
pharah
or uh widow snipe that [ __ ]
dude our reaper or our thing needs to
really oh my god
just dying in vain mike
all right junkrat's got your number how
many is there only one junkrat yeah it's
just that i keep pushing the payload by
myself
hoping and thinking that maybe
just maybe
i really want to go heal you mary but i
can't
oh my god rip
that's quite black
who's healing her uh
feel like
jesus
it's all right maybe if i just crawl
they'll never know
they'll never know
this isn't gonna work
there's no one here oh man two darbjorns
all things leave you alone yikes
dude all right you know what
no
like
oh mary got two there i don't know if
she used her alts we have no healing now
because i selfishly i'm swapping to a
character that i can hopefully deal with
these stupid
oh maybe not
oh my god they have a bastion on the
payload yikes
that's a bold move for a defensive team
god we are in trouble
oh trying to shock on you
nice
oh [ __ ]
oh
[ __ ]
he was like you know what i have bastion
alt uh you won't be teleporting by me
what will happen here can we do it
strong feeling
we're in some trouble
yeah
ooh
mr chris can't even help him
i need help so can i move
do something
oh [ __ ]
oh amazing
toast for me was there
well
we went from really strong defense to
really bad offense yeah
the defenders had at that one
we should have we should have stopped on
a high note mike
hey whatever mistakes are made unless
they can get to it
all right
uh with that
we'll see what this shitty play of the
game is though
man
all right this is a good map for junkrat
oh he could have meleed him there
oh there you go there's a melee
fire in the hole
that's the one you escaped oh never mind
dang dang we got whooped
leave as a group
don't want to see it no open my loot box
all right let's go look at your loot box
something
something
real
great double blue
got a
protoss
icon you got a who who sprays it on the
right this one
yeah it hasn't been letting me previous
race whatever
fortunately
anyways
thank you everybody for watching
i hope that you're either
thinking about playing or going to play
and whatnot so
we're gonna stream all day tomorrow as
well or most of it because we got the
lobby of course
but um yeah tune in tomorrow 10 a.m
daniel dwyer chris waters will be
in round one of the stint and then you
got mike here with me but not with me
sorry but mike will be with jake
for uh stint number two
and then um me and then i think mary
will be stint three after the lobby so
tune in then we also have a bunch of
hero guides already up on youtube so if
you're not too familiar with the
characters um you know check up on those
we've got about a third of the roster
and we're still kind of going through
some of those those are going to kind of
sprinkle you sprinkled out throughout
the week um mike's done a couple already
like yeah and some other characters so
for sure thanks mike um we did all right
i think i think
overall on average like ups and downs
yeah ups and downs pretty much um but
yeah thanks guys for watching and that
is it cool
you